bien pues digamos que tenemos una
reacción entre las moléculas de amd ok
más las moléculas de be ok y voy a decir
que esto está en un equilibrio dinámico
esto está en equilibrio ok con moléculas
de c + de ok justo esto que tenemos aquí
y bueno como estamos en equilibrio esto
significa que la velocidad de la
reacción directa va a ser la misma que
la velocidad de la reacción para atrás
de la reacción inversa ahora habrán
algunas concentraciones en el equilibrio
para abc y de y si queremos podemos
encontrar la constante de equilibrio y
es más lo voy a decir otra vez ya lo he
dicho como cuatro o más veces pero vamos
a repetirlo el hecho de que la reacción
directa sea la misma que la reacción
inversa no significa que todas las
concentraciones sean iguales las
concentraciones de cada una de las
moléculas pueden ser muy diferentes
éstas no cambian lo que estoy diciendo
cuando digo que estoy en equilibrio es
que las velocidades de reacción directa
e inversa son
ahora dado esto dado que nosotros
estamos en un equilibrio que va a pasar
si nosotros agregamos más al sistema
vamos a agregar más a al sistema vamos a
agregar más a este sistema y recuerda el
sistema estaba en equilibrio
las concentraciones eran constantes pero
ahora estoy agregando más a este sistema
ahora la probabilidad de que una
partícula y una partícula vez se
encuentren va a aumentar pero ojo no
estoy diciendo que estoy agregando más
moléculas debe al sistema las
probabilidades son ligeramente mayores
de que una a una vez vayan acondicionada
adecuadamente así que la reacción
directa va a ser más probable y bueno
entonces si agregamos más al sistema
entonces vamos a tener más moléculas a
que van a chocar con las moléculas en
cierto entonces las moléculas van a
bajar un poco esto va a bajar un poco
porque vamos a tener más moléculas ven
que están reaccionando con estas
moléculas
más moléculas be van a ser consumidas e
incluso más importante las moléculas c&d
definitivamente van a aumentar y para
eso déjame tomar otro color estas
moléculas van a aumentar porque va a
haber más reacción entre estas dos y la
manera en que sucederán si agregas más
am es que estas masas van a chocar con
más ve y de repente aumentarían la
velocidad de la reacción directa o va a
aumentar la velocidad de la reacción
directa con respecto a la reacción
inversa por lo tanto la reacción iría en
esta dirección y entonces tendrías más
seres y más de eso y esto quiere decir
que probablemente chocarán y
reaccionarán en esta otra dirección
dando eventualmente un nuevo equilibrio
pero bueno la base es que quedará algo
más de un poco menos de ve y esto es
porque no agregaste más bien y entonces
más ves será usado para consumir este
extra de amd y la reacción directa va a
producir más y más de hasta llegar a un
nuevo equilibrio y bueno hasta de una
manera lógica
pensar que si agregamos también más ve
si agregamos más vemos entonces qué es
lo que va a suceder
bueno pues agregamos masa y agregamos
más ben y esto no pienso que sea un gran
descubrimiento del mundo entonces la
reacción va a ir en dirección directa
incluso más por lo tanto va a haber más
y más de me parece que más bien es
bastante obvio que si perturban esta
reacción agregando más de este lado
entonces naturalmente se va a mover en
esta dirección
aliviando así esta perturbación si
agregas masa
entonces va a haber más jugando con más
ven y esta dirección seguirá consumiendo
algo más debes y si agregas ambas todo
el proceso va a ir en esta dirección
igualmente deja de escribir la ecuación
con otro color aunque te parece si
pensamos en lo siguiente ahora voy a
tener a ok más ve esto está en
equilibrio ok
déjame ponerlo así con temas de ok
y bueno si tú agregas ahora más
déjame ponerlo con este color agregar
más ser bueno pues que lo que me
entendiste que es lo que sucederá
siguiendo la misma idea esto nos va a
conducir a que aumente a aumente ven y
esto a lo mejor va a consumir un poco
más de adicional por lo tanto ésta va a
bajar ahora si nosotros agregamos más c
y también agregamos más de bueno pues
entonces se va a beneficiar la reacción
en esta dirección en dirección hacia
atrás por lo tanto esto va a producir
mucho más a ver esta es la idea ya sabes
parece ser que tiene bastante sentido
común pero hay un nombre de fantasía
para esto a esto se le conoce como el
principio y déjame ponerlo con este
color el principio pero sí tío ok d
lee ya te líes
t
de lujo digamos que ahora tengo a más de
ya esto le voy a agregar algo de calor
le voy a agregar algo de calor y bueno
esto está en equilibrio y para ponerlo
así va a estar en equilibrio con algo de
c + d
a más porque no le voy a agregar algo de
él entonces qué pasa hacia este mismo
sistema yo le agrego más calor y déjenme
ponerlo así le voy a agregar calor vamos
a agregarle calor bien si le agregamos
calor al sistema que va a pasar para que
la reacción progrese en la dirección
directa en esta dirección
date cuenta que necesitamos calor
mientras más calor tengamos más
probablemente la reacción progresará en
la dirección directa entonces el
principio de la lesión se les dirá que
estamos perturbando esta reacción
agregando calor entonces la reacción
favorecerá a la dirección en que se
alivie la perturbación y para aliviar la
perturbación teniendo más este reactivo
entonces vamos a tener que consumir más
y déjame ponerlo con este color vamos a
consumir masa también se va a consumir
más bien esto es porque la concentración
de a y debe disminuir a una vez que
alcancemos el equilibrio esto porque se
va a consumir más y
la reacción en este sentido sucederá más
y entonces va a haber más y más de y
bueno también más y estos tres
aumentarían ahora si llegamos justo lo
opuesto me pareció déjenme borrar todo
lo que acabo de poner déjame borrar todo
esto todo esto
ok y vamos a pensar en lo opuesto qué te
parece si ahora quitamos quitamos calor
que va a pasar bueno si quitamos calor
de toda esta reacción qué dirección será
la favorecida bien puedes darte cuenta
que vas a favorecer a la dirección
inversa porque habrá menos calor aquí y
digo en todo esto junto va a haber menos
calor para que esta reacción ocurra y
entonces esta velocidad empezará a
dominar sobre esta velocidad cierto esta
velocidad es la que va a favorecer
si quitas calor la velocidad de esta
reacción se frenará y esta otra será
mayor entonces vas a tener más
movimientos de concentración en esta
dirección o la reacción inversa será
favorecida ahora pensemos en otra
perturbación
y para eso bajemos un poco más la
pantalla para no confundirnos déjame ver
por aquí así que para esto pensamos que
tenemos el proceso deja ver que hemos
mencionado antes en el cual dice que si
tenemos gas nitrógeno y déjame ponerlo
así yo tengo nitrógeno en su forma
gaseosa ok ya esto le aumento a
hidrógeno también en forma gaseosa
entonces a esto lo voy a aumentar tres
moldes de hidrógeno en forma gaseosa ok
y esto está en equilibrio con dos moles
de amoniaco ok dos moldes de nh3 también
en su forma gaseosa de lujo ahora qué va
a pasar si le aplicamos presión a este
sistema y dejemos ponerlo así le voy a
aplicar a este sistema ok
presión
ahora la pregunta es qué va a pasar si
le agrego presión bien entonces si
piensas que va a pasar al aumentar la
presión pues todo de repente va a quedar
más aplastado el volumen se reduce al
incrementar la presión pero algo está
haciendo que todas estas moléculas
tiendan a amd o sean forzadas están más
cerca entre ellas ahora cuando están más
cerca la perturbación debido a la
presión podría aliviarse si terminamos
con menos moléculas piénsenlo de esta
forma si nosotros tenemos y déjenme
cambiar de color la forma que ve es
igual
nr de lo cual ya hemos visto varias
veces siento y si esto mismo lo
escribimos como que p es igual a n rt ok
esto dividido entre el volumen
bueno pues recuerda que nos dice el
principio del este le dice que cualquier
cosa que va a pasar va a aliviar la
perturbación la reacción va a ir en la
dirección que alivie esta perturbación
bueno si reducimos el número de molécula
entonces vamos a aliviar la presión
cierto vas a tener menos cosas rebotando
los unos contra los otros y así
reduciendo el número de moléculas puedes
ver y digo tal vez 9 debí de haber
escrito de esta fórmula porque no es una
ecuación pero quiero que lo pienses de
esta forma si nosotros aumentamos la
presión va a disminuir a esta parte de
aquí que es el número de moléculas que
va a estar rebotando las unas contra los
otros y bueno tal vez esto no sea lo más
intuitivo del mundo es más déjenme
borrarlo voy a forzar todo esto y mejor
vamos a pensarlo de la siguiente manera
me parece mucho más intuitivo si lo
pensamos así imagínate que yo tengo aquí
dos recipientes y voy a ponerlo con este
color tengo por aquí un recipiente ok
tengo por aquí otro recipiente ok
justo este de aquí y bueno voy a pensar
que en el primer recipiente tengo déjame
ponerlo con este color voy a tener una
molécula ok y bueno además tengo tres
moléculas de hidrógeno forma gaseosa así
que dejaban ponerlo así 1
23 okay tengo esta parte de aquí y en
este otro recipiente voy a tener dos
moléculas y lo voy a poner con este
color
tengo dos moléculas de amoniaco en su
forma gaseosa esta es otra forma de
decir exactamente lo mismo que estamos
en equilibrio ok
justo esto de aquí ahora qué va a pasar
se aumentó la presión y bueno tú puedes
pensar que estoy aumentando la presión
así vemos como que aumentamos la fuerza
por un área desde todas las direcciones
por aquí estoy aumentando la presión y
bueno también por acá estoy aumentando
la presión ok y bueno ahora la pregunta
sería cuál de esta situación es más
probable para aliviar la perturbación
bueno la situación donde tenemos menos
moléculas chocando alrededor porque es
más fácil aplastarlas es decir justo
aquí o me imagino apretar las que cuando
tienes más moléculas chocando alrededor
rebotando estoy haciendo esto muy
improvisado pero pienso que resulta
bastante intuitivo entonces si aplicas
presión al sistema y lo voy a poner así
ganando presión al sistema ojo esto no
quiere decir que la presión disminuya
esto quiere decir que estoy poniendo
presión a este sistema entonces cuál es
el lado de la reacción que va a ser
favorecido bueno pues el lado de
reacción que va a ser favorecido es el
de menos moléculas y este lado tienen
dos moléculas estas de acuerdo este lado
tiene dos moléculas bueno claro son dos
moléculas más grandes porque no es como
que estamos perdiendo masa en una
dirección u otra y bueno este lado se ha
favorecido en oposición a esta situación
donde tenemos cuatro moléculas correcto
un molde gas nitrógeno más tres moldes
de hidrógeno y sólo para atraer todo
esto de regreso a la idea central am y
déjame bajar un poco en la pantalla
porque vamos a hablar de un ejemplo si
yo quiero regresar a la idea central de
lo que hemos visto el principio del
échate 10 entonces déjame imaginar una
reacción como ésta y bueno esto nos va a
servir mucho para ver cómo funciona este
principio y sobre todo cómo funciona con
las constantes de equilibrio así que
imagínate que tenemos la siguiente
reacción voy a tener
los moles o bueno si lo quieres ver así
2 es el coeficiente 2a ok y bueno esto
está en estado gaseoso ok ya esto le voy
a sumar ven ya ve también lo voy a poner
en estado gaseoso ok y vamos a decir que
esto está en equilibrio o que en
equilibrio dinámico con se también en el
estado gaseoso y vamos a suponer lo
siguiente que yo tengo una concentración
de a una concentración de am de am
pueden suponer 2 molar ok 2 molar 2
molar
tengo una concentración de b y vamos a
suponer 6 molar 6 molar ok y tengo una
concentración de c
supongamos de 8 molar ok
ok si tengo estas concentraciones ahora
cuál es la constante equilibrio si
queremos sacar la constante de
equilibrio bueno pues habrá que recordar
cómo la calculábamos y bueno como ya
hemos visto la constante de equilibrio
aquí es el producto de la concentración
de sep que es 88 molar ok dividido entre
el producto de la concentración de amd
que es 2 esto elevado a la 2 porque
tenemos dos moles de amd ok
su coeficiente es 2 y esto multiplicado
por la concentración de b lo cual es 6 y
bueno esto es lo mismo que digamos 8
entre 2 por 24 por 6 24 y bueno esto es
lo mismo que un tercio ok vamos a ver
cómo funciona entonces nuestro principio
de ley ateliers así que si pensamos en
que vamos a agregar masa que va a quedar
de esto mediante que ahora mi
concentración de amd es igual a 3 molar
y ojo no estoy diciendo que estoy
agregando 1 molar seguramente agregue
más d
molar en la concentración de este
sistema pero cuál fue la cantidad de
agregada por encima de 1 no lo sabemos
con exactitud bueno fue consumida dando
lugar a esta concentración en un
equilibrio igual a 3
entonces no necesariamente agregue 1
pude haber agregado más de 1 y digamos
que nuestro nuevo equilibrio parace
vamos a ponerlo así es 12 la nueva
concentración de ser es 12 molar ok lo
cual es consistente con lo que habíamos
estudiado porque nosotros habíamos dicho
que se aumentamos a entonces se va a
aumentar también ok y tenemos que
esperar que ve la concentración debe
baje justo eso es lo que habíamos visto
hace rato y esto recuerda que es porque
un poco más debe consumirse porque va a
coleccionar con es más probable que
colisione con esas partículas de up o
moléculas de am
entonces veamos qué sucede con la nueva
concentración de ver ahora ojo recuerda
que la constante de equilibrio sigue
siendo la misma constante por lo tanto
nuestra constante de equilibrio es
un tercio entonces lo voy a poner aquí
un tercio esto va a ser igual a la nueva
concentración de ese lo cual es dos
emular ojo estoy tomando la constante de
equilibrio exactamente igual pero lo que
estamos modificando son las
concentraciones ok
12 / am la concentración de am elevada
al cuadrado lo cuales 3 elevado al
cuadrado por la concentración de b que
es justo lo que queremos y esto está
elevado a la primera potencia porque
solamente tenemos un coeficiente de 1 y
por lo tanto de aquí lo que queremos es
la nueva concentración debe y para esto
vamos a resolver un poco de aquí voy a
obtener a que un tercio es igual a 12
entre 3 al cuadrados 99
por la concentración debe ok y si ahora
cruzamos esto aunque me va a quedar
bueno de aquí voy a obtener a esto lo
voy a pasar multiplicando a esto y éste
lo voy a pasar multiplicando este y me
va a quedar que nueve veces la
concentración de ver que es justo lo que
quiero esto
exactamente lo mismo que 3 por 2 en lo
cuales 36 ok o dicho de otra manera la
concentración debe que nosotros buscamos
es igual a 44 molar y déjame ponerlo
aquí la concentración de ver la nueva
concentración de bem es exactamente
igual que 4 molar y entonces date cuenta
que esto tiene todo el sentido agregamos
un poco más a la reacción así que
empezamos con 2 molar de amd 6 molar de
pep 8 molar de cee y cuando agregamos
masa bueno al final agregamos un montón
porque muchos se fue en esta dirección a
lo mejor fue y volvió un poco pero se
estabilizó en 3 molar de a 12 molar de
se aumentó la concentración de cm y
fíjate en esto nuestra concentración de
equilibrio estable deben en realidad se
redujo en realidad se redujo y esto es
consistente con lo que estábamos
diciendo que la reacción se mueve en
esta dirección
logrando que se produzca más ce y un
poco debe se consuma de cualquier forma
es pero este es lo suficiente cómodo
ahora con la idea de perturbar la
reacción y cuando el principio de leche
del s